depends on what is it it's interesting
to see people need uh kind of structure
and guidance and stuff yeah is that what
his main kind of message is about
yeah i mean that's what his books are
about 12 rules and 12 more rules
it's all about rules for life that's
what they are uh how to and the things
that he mentions almost all of them
in the first book uh are okay with islam
in the second book there's a couple of
things that he's like abandoned ideology
which
like is to be frank ridiculous because
what do you mean by ideas um ideologies
is it a system of like set of ideas or
what is it we're talking about
and obviously you you know you can argue
that there's nothing
that does not have
an ideology everything is driven by some
sort of lens that you're looking at the
world through
so for him to write abandon ideology
but in actually other places he talks
about individualism
and he speaks about individualism
uh you know in a positive sense
you know
because that's an ideology i mean
individualism i'm not saying that he i
mean the thing is you can't really put
him in a box peterson it would be wrong
to say that he's a individual he's an
individualist
just like it would probably be wrong
some people call him a classical liberal
liberal
there's truth in that that he obviously
believes in aspects of the liberal
tradition aspects of individualism
however you know um
he's not easily put into a box because
if you look at his latest book
he talks a lot about institutions
um i think one of his rules was
something to do with preserving
institutions and following them so
that's more of a collectivist disc a
communitarian you could say not
collectives but i'll say communitarian
discourse so from that perspective
you know i mean liberals aren't
traditionally anti-communication
institutions no no i'm with you
but what i'm saying is you know it's
difficult to put them in that kind of
easy box but what i will say is
that um
saying abandon ideology
is almost an untenable venture from the
i mean probably there's probably some
specific meaning he must
he meant it in that way he definitely
meant it in that way
which is about an ideology even my own
yeah i mean abandoned i think about it
it's ironic because it's prescriptive
itself
and ideologies are more normative
um
and prescriptive so if you say abandon
ideology
the irony in it is that well that could
be an ideological statement
the statement itself is ideological what
do you think his detractors and uh kind
of dislike about
him and did you have any backlash from
your discussion with him i'm sure some i
mean he has different detractors
not everyone that disagrees with him is
wrong i mean like i said these kind of
things that we're just talking about
here there's some if you look at his
philosophical
thoughts and you know ideas some of them
are really malfunc you know
dysfunctional
they don't they don't work together
for example his pragmatism on the one
hand
i don't want to get into it's very long
story but he has
ideas which don't he's a pragmatist on
the one hand
but on the other on the other pragmatism
is basically saying that truth with a
capital t
is not
doesn't exist out there in the real
world in the corresponding stereotype
way
but on the other hand if you look at his
books
and
um how he expresses psychological
discussion
he'll
critique a theory
based on its lack of evidence
but that that presupposes a
correspondence theory of
um
there is some kind of outside outside
correspondence theory of um epistemology
right
so here's epistemology's pragmatism when
he talks about religion but for all
intents and purposes although he doesn't
spell out in this way his correspondence
when he's doing his psychology so there
is there is a tension there
and i don't think he's got it all mapped
out in fact there was one particular
discussion with sam harris that he had
not the three or four major ones that he
had because i watched all these things
and there was one particular one
where he was actually speaking about um
sam harris actually brought this up to
him
he said to him you know you you're he i
want to try and remember exactly the
words that he used
he said you can believe in what you
believe in
but it will be at your peril
and then jordan peterson responded and
this is by the way it's not even a phys
there's no video of this it's all audio
it's a podcast on sam harrison
and and then jordan peterson responds to
it and he says it has been at my peril
it's very interesting one of the most
telling things i've ever seen or heard
from jordan peterson because he's
admitting a toil
situation where he's in a toil
because he doesn't have his epistemology
worked out
and you can see that he works in this
way where for example he approaches
religion in a certain manner
where he wants truth to be malleable
and flexible
but then once again in his practice he's
not like that you know and talk about
psychology he's not like that
and i think this is causing him some
level of cognitive dissonance
there is there is a problem here in the
way in which he conceptualizes faith i
remember you saying that yeah
yeah i did say that but i didn't spell
it out and that's why you'll see that
for example in his
his genesis series which i watched
actually you know his biblical series
and stuff because you know i was
preparing i actually prepared
i watched everything and in his biblical
series
you'll see that he's metaphorizing the
text okay and at one point he actually
does quote origin of alexandria
what's that
origin of alexandria is was an
ecclesiastical church writer one of the
most voluminous of his kind in the first
300 years of christianity i think he
died 250 after the disappearance of
jesus
and he was a representative of the
alexandrian school
uh of exeter jesus
and this school was um known for
spirit whether spiritualizing the text
doing ta wheel basically you know jazz
that the text is metaphoric
and origin of alexander i did some work
on him when i was um
at the university of oxford actually i
did one
particular
study
on him
and looking at how he compared to other
church writers
they conceive of
the um
the text yeah
and basically
the alexandria school was atypical it's
aberrational compared to the other
schools
in exeter jesus
in tafsir
they're heretical
well i mean
there was something called the origin
crisis
so he was not made a saint in the
catholic church or the orthodox church
which is why he's referred to not as a
church father but as an ecclesiastic
church writer
having said that
that origin crisis happened by the way
after his death everything somewhere in
the fourth century
but the point is
that he quoted him peterson quoted
origin of alexandria
maybe in the third or fourth lecture on
the topic because he was aware of the
spiritualizing of impact
or approach that origin of alexander has
a text
however
i came across a particular um
i came across a particular
extract
where origin of alexandria was having a
discussion
with an apologist
who was a greek um
someone who believed in platonism i
think right you know platonist
who wasn't that christian
and
he said to him his name was celsius
c-l-s-u-s yeah
and he said to him
how could it be that you know i'm
paraphrasing but how could it be that
your god died on the cross basically
okay
yes
and he said
and then origin of alexander he said
um
he said the the events of the
crucifixion not all of them must be read
like literally and that some of it has
to be spiritualized basically
the point is that i'm making if you do
spiritualize the text
if you spiritualize the text meaning
metaphorize it
at the the rate and the frequency and
the degree and using the same kind of
feministic approach
someone like the origin of alexandria
was using in the early days because
that's the only precedent they really
have
he had a teacher called philo who's a
jew by the way
but he had the same kind of approach
standard approach to the biblical text
but if you
follow that
line of reasoning
then
the crucifixion itself could be
something which
is called into questions
the crucifixion itself
which means christianity becomes a myth
the entire religion of christianity
becomes a myth the crucifixion the
resurrection
um the ascension all these doctrines
that we have to the incarnation so why
is that all not mythological
um in fact what makes us think that one
is mythological and the other one is not
if these are all
this is all etiology
the idea of myth you know
and then why do we discriminate
in what we render as a myth and what we
render is
possible so
i think that jordan p because he
mentions this in maps of meaning
the big beginning of one of his books he
mentions
that when he was a young man you know he
he kind of like
he he
got doubts of christianity because of
the biblical
narrative of janice in particular
and
there's a reason for that the reason for
that is because it's obviously
not commensurate
with the scientific method or anything
scientific
but
what is completely away from it
so this is i'm thinking to myself
because he's a religious man in many
ways right he doesn't say it and if he
doesn't answer never answered once
whether he believes in god in a yes or
no fashion never
he's
the maximum he's ever said is
i act as if i believe that's why i never
asked him that question wouldn't have
even engaged him because i know he
doesn't want to answer that question you
see
but having said that
that's his answer his answer is i act as
if i believe him or as i act as if god
exists
but but despite that he's a religious
man
in the sense that he does obviously see
there's a meaningfulness to the
christian tradition in particular
comparative to other traditions
you see
um so why is he not speaking about the
vedas for example why is he not speaking
about hercules and zeus
that why are these sets of myths western
myths better than these other sets of
myths because that's his
background there must be there must be
something about these myths which make
there must be a truth about these myths
which make the
the these other sets of myth less
truthful or not as valuable or not as
worthy of being executed
or studied
that's the assumption here why of why
you spend x amount of time speaking
about the bible comparative to for
example the bhagavad gita that could be
just that's his
this is a western
yeah well so is hercules and so zeus
right that's western as well right
mithraism that's western uh
that's how it's projected now back
projected it's claimed yep but the point
is these are myths that he's chosen
you know aside from other myths
and other western myths like that right
having said all and by the way sorry to
say christianity is not a worse than
religion it's such a western
christianity yeah but christianity
started off in the middle east if you
wanted something cleanly western then
the ancient greek tradition is more no
it is because you know jesus christ was
a middle eastern man right they worship
at middle eastern man so
let's not lose sight of where
christianity actually side which is in
the middle east in jerusalem in these
places bethlehem
anyway
the point is is
why these myths are not others
for whatever reason yeah there must be
some added value of these myths and not
other myths
but then
the question is
are we how are we going to execute the
bible if we execute it all as
mythological
then it's fallen sensible it's not true
but remember he's a pragmatist
and there's a reason this is that
i don't want to
but if you're a pragmatist then you
accept different kinds of truth
but if you accept different kinds of so
you're you're able to accept the
religious truth as a separate
sub-stratum of different kinds of truth
but he's a pragmatist when it comes to
this as i've mentioned but clearly not
when it comes to even speaking about
language itself
he speaks about language in
correspondence terms he speaks about and
he's very and he seems to be very anti
deconstructulism and
that that
some argue posit
you know uh uh uh argue against
magmatism okay let me put this closer to
mind right
pragmatism neopragmatism people like
richard rorty
who are the foremost proponents of it
are the neo-pragmatists of today people
like susan hack has written a critical
inquiry um she's a neopragmatist
historically there was a group of people
called the american pragmatists
in the early 20th century they kind of
started off if you like the mother of
the the school of law
uh but so pragmatism is like that now if
you're a pragmatist you don't believe in
a truth that is out there okay richard
roti who is one of the most the foremost
pragmatists of today
was also a post-modernist
just to put this in perspective because
they they
tend to go yeah no he he's a foremost
postmodernist and he's a foremost
pragmatist can you see the tension here
richard sorry
jordan peterson in other places of his
book he attacks post-modernism
because post-modernism
clearly is is against
kind of the neocons
like conservative values which he
espouses in other places
he doesn't call it that and once again
it wouldn't be right to call him a
conservative all these caveats in place
yet
he's clearly against post-modernism
clearly
and he's clearly against nihilism but
his pragmatist views are actually so
commensurate with those things
that it's
almost inconceivable to try and
differentiate the difference like you
said he's holding two yes so so so i
actually think
that richard dawkins another must think
about whether or not
they are cognitively dissonant because
on the one hand you said richard dawkins
did i say jordan peterson
um jordan peterson
could be because when he said that time
when he was speaking to sam harris when
samhara said to him it will be at your
peril
and he said it has been at my peril what
does it mean when he said in the first
person it has been
at my peril
that means to say that he's already
found this stuff hard to conciliate
and that is causing him
discomfort which is a
which is an exact definition practically
of cognitive dissonance which is where
you come in with the go rep
which is where we come in as muslims and
say there's a solution to this problem
which is a firm anchorage one two three
which i've already explained to him in
the discussion but we have to first
diagnose the issue a bit more
uh
you know and that's why i do think you
know
that there is added value in the islamic
discourse
which which christianity cannot it
cannot actually compete with it so this
has got to be we'll talk about him why
people gravitate towards him because
he's
an anchor in the age of chaos and that's
the truth in that he offers rules and
organization and all these kind of
self-control
tactics
that's all true and good
but he hasn't yet sorted out his own
epistemology yeah he himself is
in peril according to his own discussion